OPPORTUNITY TO GIVE NEW ENERGY
TO THE RELATIONS BETWEEN
UKRAINE AND.
CHINA >> MILITARY EXPERTS ARE
WONDERING WHAT THEY'RE UP TO
AFTER LOOKING AT SATELLITE
IMAGES IS --
THIS WAS TAKEN IN FEBRUARY AND
ANOTHER MILITARY NUCHAL THERE.
>> BUT IN THIS IMAGE, FROM LATE
MARCH ALL THAT EQUIPMENT IS
GONE.
IT'S UNCLEAR WHETHER VEHICLES
REMOVED OR WHY BUT LOCAL PRE
RUSSIAN OFFICIALS SUGGEST AND
EXPECT THAT THE UKRAINIAN
COUNTER OFFENSIVE COULD TARGET
THAT AREA.
>> LET'S BRING IN CNN'S BEIJING
BUREAU CHIEF.
STEVEN JIANG.
ALSO HERE IN LONDON.
NOT A BESHEAR.
FIRST OF ALL STEPHEN THIS CALL
BETWEEN ZELENSKYY AND SHE IS
HIGHLY SIGNIFICANT AND SAYS A
LOT ABOUT XI'S POSITION ON THE
WORLD STAGE.
>> YES MAXIM BALL UGLY VERY
SIGNIFICANT AND REMEMBER THIS
HAS BEEN RUMORED FOR A LONG
TIME.
ESPECIALLY AFTER XI GAME BACK
FROM MOSCOW AFTER HIS VISIT
WITH PUTIN LAST MONTH.
AND ESPECIALLY AFTER THAT
FLURRY OF DIPLOMATIC VISITS TO
BEIJING BY EUROPEAN LEADERS AND
YOU HAVE MACRON AND VON DER
LEYEN AND ON TOP OF THAT YOU
HAVE THIS GROWING DESIRE
BUTTERNUT TO BE SEEN AS A
GLOBAL PEACEMAKER FOLLOWING THE
DEAL THEY BROKERED BETWEEN THE
SAUDIS AND IRANIANS.
SO IT'S IN THIS BROADER CONTEXT
THAT WE FINALLY SAW THIS HIGHLY
ANTICIPATED CALLED TAKE PLACE.
THAT'S ALSO WHY SOME ADULTS SEE
THIS CALL AS A REWARD FROM
BEIJING TO EUROPE'S WILLINGNESS
TO ENGAGE WITH CHINA ON THIS
ISSUE.
BUT LET'S NOT FORGET WHAT JUST
HAPPENED IN THE PAST FEW DAYS.
THE CHINESE AMBASSADOR, TO
FRANCE, CAUSING A UPROAR,
ACROSS EUROPE WHEN HE
QUESTIONED IN LIVE FRENCH
TELEVISION, THE LEGALITY OF THE
SOVEREIGNTY OF FORMER SOVIET
STATES.
EVEN THOUGH BEIJING HAS SINCE
DISOWN THOSE REMARKS THAT THE
DAMAGE HAS BEEN DONE.
SO THE NEED FOR DAMAGE CONTROL
MAY HAVE ALREADY TIP THE SCALES
IN FAVOR OF THIS RATHER MODEST
SUGGESTION ACCORDING TO SOME,
ADOLESCENT THAT'S WHY WE
FINALLY SAW THIS CALL ON
WEDNESDAY.
NOW, OF COURSE XI REITERATED
THE LONG-STANDING TALKING
POINTS.
BUT HE DID PLEDGE, FOR THE
FIRST, TIME TO SEND A SPECIAL
ENVOY TO UKRAINE.
AND OTHER REGIONAL COUNTRIES TO
DISCUSS, QUOTE UNQUOTE A
POLITICAL SETTLEMENT.
BUT EVEN STATE MEDIA HERE HAS
ACKNOWLEDGED NOTHING IS LIKELY
TO CHANGE.
AND, THE SHORT TERM GIVEN
BETWEEN RUSSIA AND THE POSITION
--
CHINA SKEPTICS AND CRITICS IN
EUROPE ABOUT THAT HOW IT'S NOT
SERIOUS TO PLAY AN UNBIASED
ROLE BY NO LIMITS PARTNERSHIP
WITH RUSSIA.
, AND ONE THING THIS CALL DOES
INDICATE OF COURSE IS THAT
CHINA IS NOT WILLING TO ENGAGE
WITH UKRAINE AND IT IS
DEFINITELY TRYING TO SHOW
EUROPE THAT IT WANTS TO PLAY A
MORE ACTIVE AND CONSTRUCTIVE
ROLE IN ENDING THIS WAR IN
EUROPE THEY'RE INCREASINGLY A
BATTLEFIELD IN THE STRATEGIC
RIVALRY IN CHINA AND THE UNITED
STATES.
MAX, BIANCA.
>> OKAY, STEVEN THANK YOU.
>> CNN'S NADA BASHIR IS HERE
FOLLOWING THE LATEST
DEVELOPMENTS FOR US IN UKRAINE.
NOT, A LOT OF MERCILESS HE SAID
THAT AT THE BEGINNING OF THE,
YEAR 2023 WOULD MARK THE
UKRAINE'S VICTORY AGAINST
RUSSIA.
IS WHAT WE'RE SEEING ON THE
BATTLEFIELD SUGGEST THAT
POSSIBILITY?
>> WELL, LOOK THE WAR IS
SUDDENLY STILL GRINDING OUT AND
WE HAVE SEEN INTENSIFICATION OF
THOSE JUST OVERNIGHT IN FACT.
WE'VE SEEN THE MYKOLAIV REGION
COME UNDER ATTACK.
BIDEN, RUSSIA ARMED FORCES HAVE
ONE PERSON CONFIRMED TO HAVE
BEEN KILLED BY THE UKRAINIAN
AUTHORITIES.
AFTER THE RUSSIAN ARMED FORCES
LAUNCHED FOUR MISSILES FROM THE
BLACK SEA.
WE'VE HEARD FROM THE UKRAINIAN
AUTHORITIES THAT THEY BELIEVE
THAT HIGH POSITION WEAPONS WERE
USED IN THAT --
MEETING THAT THE CIVILIANS,
NEEDING INFRASTRUCTURES, WERE
TARGETED DELIBERATELY AS WE
HAVE SEEN OVER THE PAST FEW
MONTHS OF THIS GRINDING.
MORE YET PRESIDENT-ELECT SKI
HAS BEEN TO THE UKRAINIAN ARMED
FORCES AND HE SPOKE THAT
YESTERDAY ADDRESSING THE SAME
THEY'RE SEE IT ANOTHER CRIME
AGAINST HUMANITY THAT THEY WILL
BE HELD ACCOUNTABLE.
BUT WE'VE ALSO SEEN FURTHER
ATTACKS IN THE ZAPORIZHZHIA
REGION.
MORE THAN 80 ATTACKS.
DRONE ATTACKS.
MISSILE ATTACKS.
ARTILLERY ATTACKS ACCORDING TO
LOCAL MILITARY OFFICIALS THERE.
THEY ARE KILLING AT LEAST TWO
PEOPLE.
SO THIS IS STILL ONGOING.
AND IT IS GRINDING ON.
WE HEARD, YESTERDAY FROM THE
U.S. MILITARY OFFICIAL
ASSESSING THE SITUATION ON THE
GROUND THAT THIS IS THE U.S.
GENERAL FOR EUROPE.
CHRISTOPHER, WE BOARDED THE
MOUND FORCES ARE ACTUALLY
LARGER AT THIS POINT NOW THAN
THEY WERE AT THE BEGINNING OF
THE WAR.
THIS IS DESPITE THE SIGNIFICANT
LOSSES THAT WE KNOW THE RUSSIAN
ARMED FORCES HAVE SUSTAINED.
AND HE ACTUALLY SAID THE
RUSSIANS ARMED FORCES STILL
HAVE PLENTY OF OPTIONS ON THE
TABLE.
SO, THIS WILL BE A SIGNIFICANT
CONCERN FOR UKRAINE.
AND OF COURSE FOR NATO AND
UKRAINE'S OTHER INTERNATIONAL
ALLIES.
BUT, THAT'S, AND CHRISTOPHER
ALSO SAID THAT THE UKRAINIANS
ARE IN A GOOD POSITION WHEN IT